microphones on shirt choices instantly
regretted 10 megavideo hi my name is
first Alex you know now you know you're
like it's different now if my neighbors
go on their porch they can definitely
see everything I'm doing so here's
hoping they have other activities to do
on a Friday night I'm in my kitchen I
[Music]
distracted by moisture I'm back in my
kitchen because today we're going to do
math just kidding I'm gonna make food
which is a form of math it's adding
things to things to make a different
thing Wow cooking is Matt why don't they
just teach cooking in high school and
get rid of Matt just like combine the
two and then kids won't know that
they're actually learning Matt because
they're learning cooking I'm a genius I
was in the grocery store the other day
and I saw these these are egg rolls
spring roll wrappers and I have never
made homemade egg rolls or spring rolls
but I didn't want to make normal egg
rolls or spring rolls I wanted to make
them really trashy real just straight up
garbage rolls because who I think I am
on the inside is just an actual can of
garbage I thought what else can I put
inside of an egg roll a spring roll that
isn't traditionally an egg roll or
spring rolls macaroni and cheese I'm
going to step some egg rolls and spring
rolls with macaroni and cheese and
create what I'm calling a matte hot G's
roll because it might be so delicious
you're going to get angry at it you can
be I got cheese so let's do it
first thing we can do is make our
macaroni and cheese this is very
self-explanatory if you don't know how
to do this right now you weren't raised
correctly I'm not looking at the
instructions on the box you're looking
at the instructions on the box you're a
box you're an instruction you suck a
dick just kidding I enjoy you right now
liquid measuring cup you get really
angry when I don't use my liquid
measuring cup and I use my dry
ingredients measuring cup ah yes okay
six cup sugar bigger measuring cup what
amazing content aren't you glad you're
here and you subscribed yet this X is of
course it is okay I'll boil this water
so haha definitely should done this
before him okay we're going to boil this
water in as much as I know that's the
content you want to see on this platform
there you high what did you diddle
yourself hold on that kind of obnoxious
fizzling noise is veggie dogs been
making Coco veggie dogs because you'll
find out later don't worry our water is
trying to boiling and I'm very impatient
so now we're going to our noodles to the
water cool accent have a good job you
guys look tiny
and then we cook them seven to eight
minutes or until they're done I don't
know why I'm just verbatim telling you
the directions that are on every box of
macaroni and cheese if you can't read
for whatever reason here is how to make
macaroni and cheese I'm not judging you
I'm just thinking of any negative things
about you
but not out loud just silently in my
head totally it's different okay we're
going to let that boil seven eight
minutes cook these veggie dogs and then
okay okay okay according to the man our
noodles are done cooking that means
we're going to drain them and then put
them back in the pot add to them make
them real pretty give them a makeover
like every 90 peeing rom-com type of
movie the water is the glasses as soon
as we take the water away and add a
couple little accessories it's like holy
she's a beautiful the whole time oh my
ribs are very supple cool
good job four tablespoons of margarine
or butter I can't believe it's not
butter at four tablespoons that's an
excessive amount Who am I to judge and
putting it inside an egg roll and I'm
deep-frying it I mean yay two three four
FL oh gosh 1/4 cup of milk
I'm very lactose insist to make this
macaroni and cheese and she's um pretty
dumb hey party and then the cheese
mixture which is this mysterious white
packet that if you saw this in any other
location other than your kitchen
straight from the box you probably
report it to the government let's put it
in the thing that we're going to put
inside our body I don't put all the
cheese mixture just like a lot than that
this seems very soupy which is not
necessarily consistency you want um your
macarons used to be is it possible that
I have stuff be possibly easiest and to
cook on the planet yeah okay wants to
cool down a little bit anyway be able to
put it in our egg roll so I'm going to
put it in the refrigerator for a little
bit that sounds crazy but there's no
other part of that button no commercial
bar mac and cheese has been in the
refrigerator for like ten minutes and it
sort of looks like mac and cheese now I
have another camera set up over here so
you'll be able to see my sleight of hand
when it comes to making these egg rolls
so the April say that they need to be
deep-fried in at least two inches of oil
so I have that going in the saucepan
here I don't know you're diddling or
whatever I chopped up my veggie dogs so
that I can add them to some of the egg
rolls and see if that makes any
delicious delightful flavor difference I
also learned that you need a beaten egg
to use as glue to roll up your egg rolls
which makes sense April's egg but I
don't have any egg so I'm going to use
water
mother nature's egg no mother nature's
egg is an egg do what happen I have my
oil already heating up so it gets to a
boiling temperature which is I don't
know I take one egg roll wrapper it
place it like a diamond shape for our
body
Oh third cup of fillings I don't know
what that means but I'm going to put
about that much in and I should put it
back this way okay so this gets rolled
over and yes I'm doing that yeah and
then you roll it like that just an
elongated roll and then this is where
you I guess you take your beaten egg and
you use it to I don't know to go to the
edges so that they fold in maybe and
then you do these edges I don't know
I've abandoned the directions i spiced
the reading got difficult and you roll
it all the way up that looks maybe like
an egg roll still looks a little bit
like an egg roll let's make a couple
more actually before we test our oil
that would be some of our chopped
veggies dog in there I don't need I can
inform word church that coconut oil for
three to four minutes here we go
oh there's no sizzle but a completely
anti climatic moment for all of us okay
this one what's that another them
[Music]
another anti-climatic moment Dutch guy I
mean they're boiling here you guys look
at it like she's happening put the other
ones in ready except these have the
meats in them I mean the fake meats is
okay ah one more oh my god
snug as bugs in a rug also I never
understood that phrase why who bugs in a
rug is not snug to me that's get up on
my house okay let's see how these go oh
my god they're boiling okay this must be
in number three to four minutes this is
so exciting let's maybe turn them over I
don't touch them no I don't like you
guys you just have to have to handle
guys are looking like egg roll oh my god
oh my god okay okay okay I don't want to
do I'm going to take them out of the
boiling oil I'm going to let them drain
off on a paper towel for a second meet
you right back here for the final
product codes I mean triple diddle okay
oh my god
tada you see this can you guys see this
oh my god oh my god oh my god these are
our mech oh geez roll and you're so
lunges macaroni and cheese I put some
sriracha on the side I didn't know what
condiments what was it and that felt
like a ketchup ish sure maybe we can use
mustard I don't ha ha move on it's so
good it's so good and so high tastes
like a neighborhood mac and cheese
inside which is essentially what we were
going for it almost exactly what we're
going for
if not exactly what we were going for a
seat I think the bigger ones have to
think meat in it well you're going to
have to you about a it's all for my love
of content creation
hah can't say [ __ ] it's too hot thank
God is it delicious because that might
be the last time that I taste anything
so I think it just burned up all of my
taste buds oh holy Sh this is really
good okay well that's the end of the
video thank you for watching I hope that
you guys try making mac cheese rolls
they're actually way easier than you
might think if you liked this video give
it a thumbs out amid all your favorite
foods in the comments down below so I
can figure out ways to come up don't
forget to subscribe to this YouTube
channel I make videos Monday Wednesday
and Friday sometime other than that I
don't know this video is a real
educational experience I've learned that
this is not the most flattering shirt
that I own and there's a good reason
that it's been hanging in my closet for
almost a year
I'm glad least one of us got an
education out of this video